yeah like aside from mcm though i mean
how is your guys experience being back
in the uk now i mean this is your second
time in the uk i don't know if it's my
second time here yeah i don't know if
you had a lot of chance to explore
england outside we've been in
like because the mcm in london is kind
of out of the way so we've kind of been
just kind of contained there right and
like the first time i was around i think
in like
2017 2018 whenever it was like i was
mostly in brighton at god's place right
so i think i was only in london for
maybe like
a day yeah yeah or so so this is i think
this will be like my first proper time
kind of like getting to check it out and
i've already seen way more of london
than i ever did last time so yeah it's
been it's been nice it's been sure i
mean the weather's been [ __ ]
fantastic this weekend as well which is
great because like everyone was like oh
yeah
when i tweeted about like oh yeah you
know i'm landing in london soon haha
it's going to be sick and yeah everyone
was just like whether it's going to be
[ __ ]
[ __ ] weather
expect the [ __ ] weather it's been really
good yeah and i landed i was just like
bro
this is is this a [ __ ] well do you guys
literally i remember the first day
meeting you i was like you couldn't ask
for like better weather it was literally
clear yeah it was clear it was like warm
like not too hot like nice and toasty
yeah bright you know perfect sunglasses
like having a coffee outside type of
weather yeah yeah and everyone was like
yo shoot weather shoot with them i was
like oh man you guys getting good here
apparently that was just like an
absolute fluke like yeah everyone was
like damn it's [ __ ] it's actually good
weather here yeah yeah yeah i think
around this time of year it's okay
though yeah yeah yeah this is a pretty
good time to come because the last time
i was in the uk it was like the biggest
heat wave in like 30 years it's like
everywhere
it's the biggest heat wave every [ __ ]
year yeah yeah one week or in your case
it was like the one month yeah of just
that was really [ __ ] hard yeah like
holy [ __ ] like the heat wave in the uk
just we are not built for it and i was
just like where's the ac
where's the ac we don't have it yeah
no i mean yeah it's been good so far i
haven't done anything oh god i dude i
had that really awkward uh
interaction at the hotel that was really
like
levels of uh awkwardness
well so we're
in the hotel bar just talking to all our
friends
you know because it's the sunday it's
after the con's ended everyone's
chilling we're all just hanging out
saying bye to all our friends and uh
this person was like pretty chill at
first and like they would come up and be
like oh hi you know do you want to drink
or anything i was like no no it's okay
it's okay yeah and i got my got my
friend to buy me a drink instead uh and
take that money
um
yeah and then they kind of like just
kept kind of you know kept saying hi
which is fine like it's chill because
people do it all the time and it's like
whatever probably a couple of drinks
deep right yeah yeah yeah like
if someone's having a drink
a bunch of drinks enjoying themselves
they want to be like oh my god yeah
yeah it's like whatever i don't mind
that yeah um but i noticed that like
whenever we would like if i went outside
or like any of you guys went outside
they would like kind of like also then
happen to go outside
at the same time yeah yeah and just
listen to whatever you were talking
about and then you know i'd go to the
toilet then suddenly okay they were in
the toilet as well and i was like okay
this is like all right a little sauce
but like nothing happened so i was like
all right cool cool cool that's chill
it's kind of like tailgating a little
bit yeah it's just kind of like watching
i guess which is like obviously it's
like not ideal but it's nothing bad like
i'm not like all right whatever uh but
then like you guys went to bed and there
was only like maybe like six of us left
we were chilling yeah and uh
there was like there was like two
couches and there's like a an empty
space because obviously you know you
guys can bed and stuff
and they came over and they were like
hey uh do you mind if i like take that
seat it's like 1am so it's kind of
winding down yeah and i was like yeah i
mean i don't really think that's like
appropriate because like no one really
knows you you anybody know me and yeah
you know it's kind of it's kind of weird
and stuff and they were like oh
okay
well do you mind if i just introduce
myself to everyone then and i was like i
was like
sorry i was like yeah no i don't i don't
think that's like the best i think you
know it's you know i i appreciate it but
like no i i it makes this a bit of a
good intention is there but it clearly
didn't quite read them yeah i was i was
trying to be like as like polite but
like
no as possible right because you know at
the end of the day like there's still
somebody who
even though i guess some people would be
like no you have the permission to be
like [ __ ] off at that point yeah cause
people just people say that i'm like i
still don't want to do that like to me
it's like they're still a person i want
to be that guy they shoot at their shot
and it didn't work and they should have
just given up at that point but then
after after i said that again i was like
no i don't think that's come on man like
no
it's kind of like stood there awkwardly
just like looking at us
and then it was just kind of like
all my friends are just looking at me
like
and i was like yeah like yeah please do
something i'm like okay
all right man
bye yeah
wouldn't leave and then
one of our friends just goes
what the [ __ ] did you say
he was like just please leave us alone
like he was begging like in like a
pleading way was like please just leave
us alone please please
i think
but that was really funny the way he
said it was
please leave us alone
yeah i mean i mean you know when you
when you hang out at the bar at the
convention in the convention hotel this
shit's gonna happen like if we really
wanted to go somewhere else and like
avoid this [ __ ]
we could have right but like we just
wanted the convenience we were all
staying in that hotel it's it's checked
so like i when people do [ __ ] like that
i know people get like really like
that's [ __ ] up that they did that i'm
like yeah it's not ideal but i'm also
like you know people get excited they
shoot their shot they didn't do anything
they they asked yeah they didn't just
sit down because people have done that
before yeah people just [ __ ] pulled
out yeah like on the panel yeah yeah
yeah yeah like i'm glad it's like i'm
glad people can now know that we aren't
bullshitting
like you can
you have the right anyone has the right
to be like hey can i join you and i have
the right to say no yeah and [ __ ] off
like exactly
like i'm not going to get pissed at
someone for trying to shoot their shot
yeah if you want to whatever yeah is it
is it kind of rude and insensitive to do
it yeah it is but at the same time but
at the same time like respect my privacy
yeah yeah if you did it respectfully i'm
gonna give you the respect to be like
explain it nicely like that's not
appropriate no and if you don't get it
maybe one of my friends won't be so nice
but i'll still be nice but
i don't know please just leave us alone
yeah i don't know
you know i i we i don't know i just say
these stories because it's like it's on
my mind i wanted to talk about it but i
i know it's gonna happen again it's
gonna be the last time uh yeah if you
ever see me around and you ask to sit
next to me i'm probably gonna say no 99
no no [ __ ] i am going to say no
i'm gonna say i'm gonna say no probably
because i don't know you and it's weird
you know and uh yeah it's like it's not
organic yeah yeah i think in a
convention setting it's hard to like
draw like a comfortable line you know
whereas maybe if you meet someone at a
bar and you're not with like a massive
group of friends it's different it's
different it's different yeah definitely
it's very it's very different it's like
it you kind of do have to like read the
room sometimes which i know some people
aren't as in tune with that as other
people but you know you try not to hold
things against people unless they like
seriously do cross like a social
boundary yeah you know
um
in which case maybe i should listen to
[ __ ] died as more and just be like
sorry man yeah man
did she's the man
for 10 minutes just being like no no
here's another here's another reason why
no here's another reason why no if you
would have just said sorry man then that
would be like all right man i respect
that
that's what we should have said to that
guy who came on stage [ __ ] he was right
all along just turned and being like
sorry man
sorry man let's just say the place now
man
there was this one dude that i i like
she doesn't like know what his deal was
i was like we were at the bar with john
and john was talking to me and i was
like john man yeah it sucks dude like
you know i was like yeah it kind of
sucks
but we've said john like a million times
right
it's literally such a common name i was
in my own head i'm sorry yeah yeah okay
that's my bad i suck dude
i was telling super eye patch i was like
yeah man sucks dude like you know i
don't feel like i can't really like
experience a con the way i used to and
then
while i'm telling this story to john
this guy who must have been like 40 or
50 just shouts full on from across the
bar he's like hey connor
connor you want a drink
you want a drink and i'm like nah i'm
good man
and john was like you know that guy i'm
like not a [ __ ] club
it's just so weird i i i get it because
that's happened that happened to me a
few times
he was nice enough he just asked me and
i was like that was it that was it that
was like because like they they shout
your name in such familiarity that even
i'm even i have to double take to be
like do i know this yeah dude you know
what i mean
like a few times when i hang out with
mates like over here like go on hey gone
gone and i'm just like oh it's uh i
wait i i don't i've never met this man
in my life it's like a friend of a
friend no
yeah
don't you don't offer me a drink i'm
privileged as you all say so don't [ __ ]
it i don't need it buy his own drink i
buy my own one i promise i appreciate it
though some people you know is nice you
know i i had one time i was in london
last time i never told this there's like
someone um in like a mexican restaurant
it was like the thing in the movie it
was like the person over there wants to
buy you a drink
that came over i was like this is
[ __ ] cool yeah yeah i'll have it and
then you bought me like the strongest
drink on the [ __ ] menu and i was like
it's like trying to spike so yeah so
then i realized i was like yeah i'm not
doing this again
i'm not letting them choose the drink
the weirder one for me is like the ones
where it's like just in passing but
you're also like not too sure either
because of the lack of information like
it's the ones where you're like when
you're in the hotel lobby and you're
trying to get to the toilet or something
and then a person is walking past you
and you just very briefly
have eye contact and they just go
like
and then they walk off and i'm just like
do i know
do i know
like this is like something like number
23 yeah yeah
wake up because i wake up
that doesn't happen a lot it does happen
a lot and i'm just like and it's not
until i turn around and sometimes
they'll turn around be like you know
like hey love your stuff and i was like
i hope you're having a good night and
stuff like that you know maybe they're
just being friendly i don't know but
it's like it's just the silent nod
like what is this code for something
like
yeah
but uh that's cool though sorry it's
cool like that's the one thing i i guess
as well that i've just been like kind of
getting back used to again because yeah
you know because i personally have been
stuck in japan for the past three years
now and it's like yeah stranger
friendliness is not as big of a thing as
it is saying like the uk right yeah
especially in a con setting so it's like
i'm just getting used to just random
people just being like hey yeah we've
gone through like
i feel like it has been like just us
readjusting and re-acclimating to con
culture because it's been like such a
we've gone from like zero to like 200
percent you know and like in like the
span in like the span of a day and it's
just like i've forgotten one how intense
it was before like before covered and
everything and now it's like even more
intense because one cove has happened
everyone's even more excited and
enthusiastic um and also we are way more
recognizable so it's just kind of like
all culminated into this massive
stirring pot i i know like for me it was
i know like i caught myself being like
oh man it's been such a long time since
i've been to a con because there's so
many times during the signing where like
you know because you're meeting so many
people right you start to get into like
a pattern of things to say yeah right
it's like it's like you start off with
the hello like how's your con experience
been how's your day been whatever and
then there was so many times where like
people would be like i hope you enjoy
your time in the uk and i'll be like
yeah you too
as if they're not from here
well there was a lot of people actually
who are like not from the uk yeah but
it's like it's like clearly i i every
time i send you two to that question it
was always the most like british
sounding person ever
it's like yeah as if they don't [ __ ]
leave yeah it's like damn it i think i
said that a few times not to that but
like oh thanks a lot for your content i
go you too
[Laughter]
so how did you know
i had a okay it's not not a con
experience uh we got it we had a cab
back uh me joey and a few other friends
and it was like
it was like a 41 pounds this is this cab
ride so it was like 30 minutes it was a
long time yeah and uh you know i went to
go pay i gave the guy cause i only had
like 10 so i gave the guy 50. right
and i so i'm my head right i'm like okay
it's been like three years or like since
i've been like tipping
normally and i know that sometimes you
tip cab drivers in london and stuff and
i was like okay yeah yeah i forgot about
this because i never took cabs and i
lived here before yeah yeah obviously it
was late and we were in like the middle
of nowhere so
i i pay this guy and then he's like oh
yeah
i'll i'll give you the change just get
out the car and i'll give you the change
so i you know you know i get out the car
i'm kind of just tired it's like 3am
like i just want to go to bed yeah and
so the guy
uh i was like all right so can i have my
change because i the way i i tip i don't
know if you do this like i want all my
change first and then i
yeah and so
i was like oh can i have my change and
he was like
what
it like he looked at me like he like he
i asked for change and then he just
looked at me like he wanted me to take
it back like he wanted me to pretend
like i should say something yeah like
like i was like i was like bro what the
[ __ ] like i i was gonna tip him and then
he's now he's being weird about it and
now i want to tip him less because i'm
like i'm like just give me my [ __ ]
i'm like nine pounds is a lot right yeah
this is not america we don't tip 20 yeah
right like i i was gonna give him like a
fiver that was my plan and then i was
like you're being weird about this man
just give me my [ __ ] money back yeah
and i'll give you some bags like i was
like what the [ __ ] dude and so that's
not cool and so i i like i'm like all
right yeah i was like can i my change
and then he like looks at me again i
want to say it was the most awkward five
to ten seconds of my life that's right
it felt like zawarido and jojo yeah i
could feel the one second
two seconds and i feel i feel like he
was trying to figure out if i was drunk
like right i was fine but i felt like he
was trying to see if he was like can i
get away with this
and so he goes into his car he like
rummages around and he comes out and he
just gives me five pounds and i'm like
i'm like
dude
all right okay fine ready fine he's
probably thinking like maybe if i just
give him some money
i was going to give you the five pound
notes now you've got four pound because
you're being a dick yeah and i'm like
why just just give me my money back and
i'll tip you i was like what the [ __ ]
and i was just like what a weird
experience yeah meanwhile the people in
the camp were just like vibing they're
like no i'm like having like this mind
battle with this cab driver they'd like
just tip him i should give him money and
he was making it weird i was like this
why are people like this yeah everyone
was like everyone else was in the car
just like kind of chatting and i'm just
like yeah just like dead on the [ __ ]
back seat
not knowing that that's what it is i was
just like bro okay and so he got his
four pound tip jokes on you you got a
five pound tip you just give me all my
change dude
yeah
because that's such a weird experience
you don't get in japan you don't you
don't no you don't
like they just give you it back
immediately and you never have to deal
with this and it was just so weird just
seeing the guy just not want to give me
my [ __ ] change and i was just like
it's like me no speaking